SOLUTION.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Dana: YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING PRESIDENT TRUMP HOST AN
UNPRECEDENTED AND EXTRA ORDINARY
ROUNDTABLE ON SCHOOL VIOLENCE.
MANY PEOPLE THEY ARE IN
ATTENDANCE HAVE EITHER BEEN AT A
SCHOOL SHOOTING OR THEY LOST
THEIR LOVED ONES IN THE SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
ONE OF THE GREAT POWERS OF THE
PRESIDENCY IS THE POWER TO
CONVENE.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE HAVE NOT
SEEN BEFORE, ESPECIALLY ON THIS
ISSUE WHERE YOU HAD SUCH RAW
EMOTION, OUTPOURINGS OF GRIEF.
THE PRESIDENT LISTENING SUPER
INTENTLY TO ALL OF THEM.
ASKING ABOUT IDEAS.
IT WAS A VERY EMOTIONAL AND
MOVING DAY, BUT IT ALSO GAVE YOU
SOME HOPE THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME ACHIEVEMENT GOING FORWARD.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE’S GOING TO
HAVE THEM BACK THAT THEY WOULD
BE COMING BACK IN A MUCH BETTER
LIGHT, MEANING HOPEFULLY THEIR
GRIEF WOULD SUBSIDE BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT, THEY ARE GOING TO
ACT.
JESSE WATTERS, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> Jesse: AMERICA HAS REACHED
A TIPPING POINT ON SCHOOL
VIOLENCE.
SOME OF US WERE TEARING UP
WATCHING THE EXCHANGES.
IT WAS REALLY A RAW AND ORGANIC
AND POWERFUL MOMENT.
THE PRESIDENT TAKES IN
INFORMATION VERBALLY.
THAT’S HOW HE TAKES HIS
BRIEFINGS.
HE WAS AFFECTED WHEN HE SAW THE
PICTURES OF THE SYRIAN CHILDREN.
HE TALKS ABOUT BEING A
PROTECTOR.
PROTECTING THE BORDER,
PROTECTING JOBS AND IT’S UP TO
HIM TO DO WHATEVER HE CAN TO
PROTECT THE SCHOOLS.
A LOT OF POLITICIANS ARE ALL
TALK AND NO ACTION.
HE’S NOT ONE OF THEM.
I BELIEVE.
HE WANTS TO TAKE ACTION THAT’S
GOING TO HAVE AN IMPACT, NOT
JUST EMPTY ACTION THAT’S NOT
GOING TO SOLVE ANY PROBLEMS.
HE TALKED ABOUT MAKING AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN.
SAFE AGAIN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED IS SCHOOL SAFETY.
THE BEST MOMENT, ANDREW POLLACK,
HE LOST HIS DAUGHTER MEADOW, HE
SAID FORGET ABOUT THE GUN ISSUE.
LET’S FOCUS ON MAKING SCHOOLS
SAFE.
THERE WERE SOME GREAT EXCHANGES
OF IDEAS, ARMING TEACHERS AT
SCHOOLS, ENHANCED BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
THIS KID HAD BEEN SUSPENDED.
NO ONE INTERVENE.
MY FATHER RAN A SCHOOL IN
LONG ISLAND.
AFTER SANDY HOOK, THEY BUILT
FENCES AROUND THE SCHOOL.
YOU CANNOT PEOPLE JUST WANDERING
IN.
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS IN
THE URBAN AREAS, THEY HAVE METAL
DETECTORS AND CHECKPOINTS WHICH
ARE EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE.
THAT’S SOMETHING TO LOOK AT TOO.
ANOTHER GREAT MOMENT WAS WHEN A
GUY, I BELIEVE FROM SANDY HOOK,
ONE OF THE FATHERS SAID WE STOP
RELYING ON WASHINGTON TO FIX
EVERYTHING AND WE DID OURSELVES.
WE TAUGHT TEACHERS TO INTERVENE
WHEN THEY SAW STUDENTS WITH
PROBLEMS AND TAKE ACTION
AGGRESSIVELY.
THE BEST MOMENT I THINK AT THE
END, THE GUY SAID LISTEN, WE
HAVE LOST OUR CONNECTIONS.
AS HUMANS, AS AMERICANS.
WE DON’T RECOGNIZE PEOPLE
ANYMORE.
WE DON’T SEE THINGS.
WE MISS SIGNS.
THAT’S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMETHING, SAY
SOMETHING.
AMERICANS, WE ARE ALL ONE
NATION.
WE HAVE TO CARE FOR ONE ANOTHER.
I THINK THIS IS A STARTING POINT
FOR SOME STRONG ACTION.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT CONCRETE THINGS HE IS
THINKING ABOUT.
THE AGENT WHICH YOU CAN BUY A
GUN, THAT IS SET FEDERALLY.
HE TALKED ABOUT BACKGROUND
CHECKS, CONCEALED CARRY.
HE MENTIONED THAT SEVERAL TIMES.
PEOPLE IN A SCHOOL THAT WOULD
HAVE A GUNBOAT YOU WOULDN’T KNOW
WHERE THAT MIGHT BE.
>> Greg: THE INTERESTING FOR
FOR -- INTERESTING THING FOR ME,
NOT JUST THE SUGGESTIONS BUT THE
TONE AND TENOR OF THE
CONVERSATION IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE MAKE JOKES
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT REVIEWING
HIS ADMINISTRATION IS A TALK
SHOW.
SO WHAT?
THAT WAS ONE HELL OF A
TALK SHOW.
YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
SITTING THERE WHO KNOW THE TOPIC
AND EXPRESSED SUGGESTIONS,
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS ABOUT A
HORRIBLE PROBLEM.
MY ADVICE ALWAYS STANDS.
THE BIGGEST OBSTACLE IN THIS
DEBATE IS TRUST.
THE LOUDEST VOICES DO NOT TRUST
EACH OTHER.
THOSE WERE NOT THE LOUDEST
VOICES.
THOSE WERE THE VOICES YOU HAD TO
LISTEN TO.
WHAT YOU FOUND WERE PEOPLE WHO
DISAGREED BUT THEY DISAGREED
CIVILLY.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST VALUABLE THINGS I
HAVE SEEN IN THIS ADMINISTRATIO
ADMINISTRATION.
I ALSO, TO JESSE’S POINT,
DARRELL SCOTT WILL, HIS DAUGHTER
DIED AT COLUMBINE.
>> Dana: NO, JUST RECENTLY.
>> Greg: DARRELL SCOTT.
HIS POINT WAS ABOUT CONNECTION.
WHAT WE SAW WAS CONNECTION.
WE ARE TOO BUSY, IN THIS WORLD
OF DIVISION RIGHT NOW.
WHAT GROUP DO YOU BELONG TO, THE
TRIBALISM THAT INFECTS
EVERYTHING FROM POLITICS TO
IDENTITY.
WHAT HE WAS TRYING TO SAY IS WE
NEED TO CONNECT.
WE CONNECT IN BROADBAND.
THAT’S NOT THE REAL THING.
WE HAVE COMMUNITY.
THE THING IS COMMUNITY MEANS
INTERACTION BETWEEN POLICE AND
THE PEOPLE THEY POLICE.
IT’S A COMMUNITY.
IT’S AT SPORTING EVENTS,
SCHOOLS.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHO WAS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND NEED TO BE
CONFIDENT ENOUGH.
THERE WAS A BINDER FULL OF
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS THERE.
THEY COULD BE ACTED UPON.
THEY WERE PRESENTED IN A WAY
THAT WAS NONTHREATENING TO
EITHER SIDE, THAT’S WHAT
COMMUNICATION AND CONNECTION IS
ABOUT.
>> Dana: WE HAVE THIS
SOUND BITE FROM DARRELL SCOTT.
>> I WANT TO SHARE ONE SIMPLE
PRINCIPLE WITH YOU THAT WE HAVE
LEARNED OVER THE YEARS AS WE
WORKED WITH MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT COMES FROM SOMETHING YOU SAID
LAST WEEK IN YOUR SPEECH.
IT WAS THAT WE MUST CREATE A
CULTURE OF CONNECTEDNESS.
WE MUST CREATE A CULTURE IN
WHICH OUR CLASSMATES BECOME OUR
FRIENDS.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS HAVE BEEN FROM YOUNG
MEN WHO ARE DISCONNECTED.
AND WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES BUT IT
ACTUALLY GOES DEEPER THAN THAT
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT OF
MENTALLY ILL CHILDREN THAT ARE
KIND AND COMPASSIONATE.
THE FOCUS REALLY NEEDS TO BE ON
HOW CAN WE CONNECT.
>> Dana: THAT WAS POWERFUL FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WE WANTED TO PLAY THAT
SOUND BITE FOR YOU.
>> Juan: I THINK TODAY IS A
WONDERFUL DAY IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
HEARING VOICES.
EARLIER TODAY, YOU HAVE THE
STUDENTS FROM PARKLAND WHO WENT
TO TALLAHASSEE TO THE STATE
CAPITAL IN FLORIDA.
THEY ARE ARGUING THERE THAT
AGAIN, WE NEED ACTION.
THEY ARE TIRED OF THE
STATUS QUO.
IT WAS AMAZING -- AN AMAZING
TURNOUT.
I WAS STRUCK BY THE IDEA THAT
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE 15,
16 YEARS OLD.
MOST OF THEM WERE NOT SENIORS.
SOME OF THEM WERE HIGH SCHOOL
FRESHMAN, BUT THEY SPOKE WITH
SUCH PASSION.
SOME OF THEM CHOKING BACK TEARS
TO TRY TO EXPRESS NOT ONLY THEIR
FEARS BUT WHAT THEY HAD LOST.
SIMILARLY, I THINK AT THE
WHITE HOUSE MEETING, THE ABILITY
TO HEAR FROM YOUNG PEOPLE REALLY
STRIKES ME AS WHAT’S DIFFERENT.
IT CHANGES THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE YOU CAN SAY OH, WELL,
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE DON’T HAVE
CONCRETE IDEAS OR BETTER IDEAS.
BUT I THINK THEY ARE TOUCHING
SOMETHING AT THE AMERICAN
SPIRIT, SAYING WE HAVE TO FIND A
SOLUTION.
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO WHAT WAS
BEING SAID, FOR EXAMPLE, AT THE
WHITE HOUSE MEETING.
I THINK IT HAS A PUBLICITY ANGLE
BUT I DON’T THINK THAT’S --
THAT’S NOT WHAT YOU GET
SOLUTIONS.
WHAT YOU HEAR IS THIS GOES
BEYOND SCHOOLS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING MY KIDS
WALKING HOME FROM SCHOOL OR MY
KIDS WALKING OVER TO AN AP
PROGRAM OR MY KIDS WAITING AT
THE BUS STOP.
THERE ARE SO MANY GUNS AROUND.
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH IT?
HOW DO YOU STOP IT?
THAT’S THE CHALLENGE.
BUT AS SOMEONE SAID, WE HAVE
TONS OF IDEAS FOR SOLUTIONS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, GUN OWNERS
AND NONGUN OWNERS.
NRA AND NONNRA AGREED BASICALLY
ON BACKGROUND CHECKS, LIMITING
WEAPONS THAT BECOME WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION.
PEOPLE AGREE ON WHO AND
ARGUMENTS ABOUT GUN SAFETY AND
PREPAREDNESS AND WAITING
PERIODS.
THESE ARE ALL VERY CONCRETE
IDEAS.
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE, THE
WOMAN WHO STOOD UP AND SAID MOST
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ARE NOT THE ONES WHO ARE
SHOOTING UP THE PLACE.
THAT’S A DODGE FROM A DIFFICULT
ISSUE OF DEALING WITH THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A PROLIFERATION OF
GUNS.
MORE GUNS AND PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
IT’S CRAZY.
>> Dana: KIMBERLY, I WILL GIVE
YOU A CHANCE TO REMARK ON
ANYTHING YOU WANT.
>> Kimberly: THANK YOU.
LISTENING TO THE STUDENTS
EXPRESSING THEMSELVES SO
PASSIONATELY AND ELOQUENTLY THAT
THEY WANT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
THE PASSION AND BECAUSE OF THEIR
LIFE AND THEY WEREN’T GOING TO
FORGET IT.
WE OWE THAT TO THE CHILDREN, THE
STUDENTS OF AMERICA, TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN THEY GO THROUGH
THE SCHOOL DOORS IN THE MORNING
AND THE BELL RINGS TO GO SIT AND
PAY ATTENTION IN CLASS THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE
LESSON AND NOT WORRY ABOUT A
GUNMAN COMING THROUGH THE DOOR
TO KILL THEM.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO HONOR
THE LIVES OF THOSE THAT WERE
LOST AND THOSE THAT GAVE THEIR
LIVES TRYING TO SAVE OTHERS AND
IN PARTICULAR, YES, WE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT THE COACH WAS
INCREDIBLE AND ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO SHOWED INCREDIBLE VALOR IN
THE FACE OF TREMENDOUS
ADVERSITY.
INSTEAD OF COWERING IN FEAR,
THEY RAN TOWARDS TO TRY TO SAVE
LIVES, LIKE THE JUNIOR ROTC
MEMBERS THAT WERE ABSOLUTELY SO
INCREDIBLE.
PETER WANG, 15 YEARS OF AGE.
ALAINA PETTY, 14 YEARS OF AGE.
AND MARTIN DUQUE, ALSO 14.
IMAGINE YOU HAVE THE PRESENCE OF
MIND AND THE SELFLESSNESS TO SAY
THAT I WILL STAND IN THE WAY SO
OTHERS MAY LIVE.
>> Dana: REMARKABLE TRAINING
FROM THE ROTC.
>> Kimberly: IMAGINE IF ALL
THE STUDENTS WERE EQUIPPED WITH
THAT KIND OF TRAINING AND WE
GAVE THEM THE MEANS BY WHICH TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND WE MADE
SCHOOLS A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
SAID I’M NOT GOING TO GO THERE
TO COMMIT AN ACT OF VIOLENCE.
I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PERMEATE
THE AIR AND GO AND DO SOMETHING
AND COMMIT THESE HORRIFIC ACTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE PROTECTED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT THE
MEDIA DID ABOUT THAT?
THEY BLAMED THE ROTC.
>> Dana: THEY DID?
>> Greg: THAT THE KILLER WAS
ALSO TRAINED.
>> Dana: OH.
>> Greg: INSTEAD OF WHAT
KIMBERLY ACUTELY POINTED OUT.
PETER WANG, WEST POINT HAS
ADMITTED HIM.
THE THREE JUNIOR ROTC CADETS OR
MAYBE JUST PETER WANG.
THREE DIED.
>> Kimberly: HE WANTED TO GO
TO WEST POINT.
>> Dana: THEY GAVE HIM A
POSTHUMOUS ENTRANCE INTO THE
ACADEMY.
WE HAVE THE SOUND FROM ANDREW
POLLACK, AS JESSE, HIS DAUGHTER
MEADOW DIED LAST WEEK ON
WEDNESDAY, A WEEK AGO TODAY.
>> MY DAUGHTER HAS NO VOICE.
SHE WAS MURDERED LAST WEEK.
SHE WAS TAKEN FROM US.
SHOT NINE TIMES ON THE THIRD
FLOOR.
I AM VERY ANGRY THAT THIS
HAPPENED.
IT KEEPS HAPPENING.
9/11 HAPPENED ONCE, AND THEY
FIXED EVERYTHING.
HOW MANY SCHOOLS, HOW MANY
CHILDREN HAVE TO GET SHOT?
IT STOPS HERE WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND ME.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ONE SCHOOL
SHOOTING AND WE SHOULD HAVE
FIXED IT.
AND I AM PISSED.
MY DAUGHTER I AM NOT GOING TO
SEE AGAIN.
SHE IS NOT HERE.
I DIDN’T THINK IT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO ME.
IF I KNEW THAT, I WOULD’VE BEEN
AT THE SCHOOL EVERY DAY IF I
KNEW IT WAS THAT DANGEROUS.
IT’S ENOUGH.
GET TOGETHER.
WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT AND FIX
THE SCHOOLS.
>> Dana: HIS PASSION IS
CERTAINLY EVIDENT BUT ALSO TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO COME TO THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH YOUR SONS,
ARTICULATE YOURSELF THAT WELL
AND MAKE SURE YOU ARTICULATE
THAT IT DOESN’T HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Jesse: HE REALLY LIT A FIRE
UNDER THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK THAT WAS THE MOMENT OF
THE ENTIRE EVENT THE PEOPLE
REALLY BEGAN TO THINK THIS IS
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
YOU COULD NEVER LISTEN TO
SOMEONE TALK LIKE THAT THAT
PASSIONATELY AND FORGET IT A FEW
WEEKS LATER.
SOMETHING ELSE INTERESTING TO
ME.
WE PROTECT EVERYTHING WE VALUE
IN THIS COUNTRY WITH GUNS.
WE PROTECT BANKS.
WE PROTECT POLITICIANS,
CELEBRITIES.
WE PROTECT CONGRESSMEN.
EVERYTHING WE VALUE, WE PROTECT
WITH GUNS.
WHY DON’T WE PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN WITH GUNS?
THE 9/11 ANALOGY IS REALLY
CRITICAL.
EVERY SCHOOL SHOOTING IS A MINI
9/11 FOR THAT SCHOOL AND FOR
THOSE FAMILIES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
TO HAVE IT HAPPEN OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, WE HAVE REACHED
CRITICAL MASS IN THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
MOMENT.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THE
TIPPING POINT?
DO YOU THINK CULTURALLY, MAYBE
IT’S DIFFICULT TO GET THE
LEGISLATION THROUGH BUT IT WILL
HAPPEN THIS YEAR?
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW.
WE LIVE IN A STRANGE TIME WHERE
THE NEWS HAS ACCELERATED SO
QUICKLY.
I AM STILL -- LIKE, WE DON’T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN VEGAS.
THIS WAS UTTERLY PREVENTABLE.
WE SAW HOW MANY MISTAKES.
WE STILL DON’T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE VEGAS THING.
I DON’T THINK THERE WAS A
POSSIBLE WAY YOU COULD HAVE
STOPPED VEGAS BECAUSE WE DON’T
EVEN KNOW HOW LONG HE PLANNED.
WHEN SOMEBODY PLANS SOMETHING,
IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IF SOMEBODY IS SMART AND HAS A
PLAN.
I HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE.
9/11 WAS THE SECOND TIME, RIGHT?
THE SECOND ATTACK ON THE WORLD
TRADE CENTER.
THEY WENT BACK AND PLANNED.
THEY TRIED IT ONCE AND THEY CAME
BACK AND DID IT AGAIN.
AS LONG AS THERE IS EVIL IN THE
WORLD, THERE WILL BE THESE
INCIDENTS AND WE CAN’T EXPECT
THEM TO DISAPPEAR LIKE THAT.
HOWEVER, I WILL SAY THIS.
THESE PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY PRACTICAL.
I HEARD A MOTION BUT I ALSO
HEARD RATIONALITY.
IT WASN’T SIMPLY PEOPLE SHOUTING
"DO SOMETHING."
WHAT YOU HEARD WERE PEOPLE WHO
WERE ACTUALLY EXPRESSING
PRACTICAL, RATIONAL SOLUTIONS TO
A PROBLEM.
THAT’S ALREADY IN MY MIND
PROGRESS AND WE ARE ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT IT.
I WOULD SUGGEST, SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
I HAVEN’T SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE BUT A TOWNHOME LIKE
THIS, PERTAINING TO OTHER ISSUES
LIKE THIS.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE INTIMATELY
INVOLVED, INVOLVING THE
PRESIDENT.
IT’S AN INTERESTING THING AND
COULD BE SOMETHING.
AGAIN, GO BACK TO DONALD TRUMP.
HIS PRESIDENCY IS A TALK SHOW.
MAYBE THAT’S NOT SO BAD BECAUSE
THAT’S THE TALK SHOW YOU NEED.
>> Juan: I DON’T AGREE.
I THINK YOU’RE GOING TO NEED TO
HAVE SOME KIND OF RESOLUTION
WITH THE RIGHT WING TALK SHOW
HOSTS AND NRA, THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL SAY YOU’RE TAKING AWAY MY
GUNS.
>> Greg: IT GOES BACK TO THE
TRUST ISSUE.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU HAVE A
MEETING LIKE THIS, IT’S TERRIFIC
IN TERMS OF HAVING A CATHARTIC
MOMENT.
I THINK FOR ALL OF US AS A
COUNTRY TO HEAR THE PAIN IN THE
FAMILIES, TO UNDERSTAND IT’S
LIKE A 9/11.
IT’S YOUR CHILD COMMITS HER
FAMILY.
THAT MAN STANDING UP THERE
SAYING HE WILL NEVER SEE HIS
DAUGHTER AGAIN.
WHY DIDN’T WE FIX THIS?
THAT’S POWERFUL STUFF.
BUT IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY